Ласкаво просимо до Парми, штат Огайо.
Тихе містечко з населенням 80 тисяч стало центром боротьби за підтримку України Сполученими Штатами.
Майже половина населення має українське походження. Традиційно вони підтримували республіканців. Але цього року все може змінитися.
Ця пекарня знаходиться в самому серці Парми і відома своїми українськими стравами.
Наші вареники добре відомі в усьому світі, тому що ми маємо деякі додаткові смаки разом із традиційними.
Мати Лідії, сама біженка з України, стала власницею пекарні ще в 1974 році.
Коли ми почули про війну тієї ночі, коли стався перший напад, ми всю ніч не спали, тому що в мене в Україні є двоюрідні брати і сестри.
Тож, одразу ж наступної суботи ми пожертвували на потреби України всі кошти від продажу вареників.
Тоді зібрали близько 10 тисяч доларів. Ця війна не просто тисячі миль звідси - вона прямо тут, вона на нашому порозі,
вона у наших телефонах, вона в наших електронних листах, вона відбувається з нами, і це те саме, що сталося з нашими батьками, які переїхали сюди.
Напередодні виборів ця підтримка стала дуже політизованою в штаті Огайо.
Джеймс Девід Венс - кандидат у Сенат від Республіканської партії. І ось яка його позиція.
Підхід America first не має ігнорувати проблеми власної країни, зосереджуючись натомість на Україні.
Давайте зосередимося на власних проблемах наших громадян і будемо ігнорувати кандидатів, які хочуть,
щоб ми вели війну з Володимиром Путіним, тому що це змушує їх відчувати себе крутими.
Це звучить дуже занепокійливо для людей, які переживають за ситуацію в Україні.
А їхні голоси важливі, бо результати в Огайо непередбачувані і голосування етнічних українців може стати вирішальним.
Я думаю, що це ганьба, що це стало питанням, яке поляризується у США. Коли розпочалася війна, була підтримка обох партій.
Я постійно голосував за консерваторів, але я не буду голосувати за цього Джеймса Девіда Венса,
тому що він не представляє консервативну філософію, до якої я належу.
Досвідчений республіканський істеблішмент Огайо та США розуміє важливість України та підтримує Україну.
Але протрампівські республіканці, схоже, що ні.
Наші діти дивляться, що саме ми залишимо для наступного покоління. Це про них. Це про дітей, які не мають дому.
Для багатьох тут, у Пармі, підтримка України - це не політика, це питання життя чи смерті,
і це може змусити багатьох американців українського походження проголосувати не за республіканців, а за демократів.
Нагадаємо, проміжні вибори (midterms) проходять у США в середині чотирирічного президентського терміну.
І якщо зазвичай ЗМІ приділяють їм набагато менше уваги, ніж президентським, то цього разу їхні результати можуть істотно
вплинути на розстановку сил у Вашингтоні та, відповідно, на світову політику.
Під час проміжних виборів переобирається вся Палата представників, тобто 435 місць у нижній палаті Конгресу США,
а також трохи більше третини місць зі 100 у Сенаті.
За традицією, проміжні вибори є чимось на кшталт лакмусового папірця щодо підтримки виборцями чинного президента та його партії.
Як правило, на проміжних виборах партія президента не досягає добрих результатів,
і одна з головних речей, які можна побачити, - це рівень схвалення президента та стану справ в економіці.
За тиждень до виборів багато аналітиків прогнозують, що американські виборці, невдоволені насамперед
економічною ситуацією і, зокрема, зростанням цін та інфляції в країні, забезпечать республіканцям справжній переможний "вал".
Водночас деякі спостерігачі оцінюють ситуацію з точністю до навпаки.
Демократи не приречені. Результат виборів далеко не вирішений. Більшість висновків про те, як пройдуть
проміжні вибори, неправильні й засновані на нерозумінні даних про вибори.
Так уже історично склалося, що партія, яка контролює Білий дім, зазвичай програє на проміжних виборах.
Але це відбувається не через те, що насправді думають люди…
Справжня причина полягає в тому, що виборці правлячої партії заспокоюються і не приходять на вибори в тій самій кількості, що й на президентські,
тому зараз все залежатиме від явки, скільки з цих виборців знову прийдуть на вибори.
Саме це і визначить, чи переможуть демократи, чи втримають вони Палату представників і чи збільшать свою перевагу в Сенаті.
Обидві партії проводять кампанії на ключові теми, які хвилюють їхніх виборців.
Зараз є п'ять, можливо, шість сенатських перегонів, де, за опитуваннями, обидва кандидати перебувають у межах арифметичної похибки один від одного.
Це Аризона, Невада, Джорджія, Вісконсин, Пенсильванія та, можливо, Північна Кароліна.
І те, які теми нинішніх виборів є найважливішими, багато в чому залежить від того, з ким ви розмовляєте.
Для багатьох республіканців, незалежних кандидатів та демократів - це інфляція та економіка.
Електорат республіканців схильний більше цікавитися питаннями імміграції та безпеки.
Демократи вважають обмеження права на аборти однією з головних тем, яка хвилює їхніх прихильників.
Боротьба за темношкірих виборців, переважна більшість яких завжди голосувала за демократів, цього разу обіцяє бути особливо жорстокою.
Адже, згідно з опитуваннями, багато хто з них розчарований політикою нинішньої адміністрації.
Щоправда, на користь демократів вказує той факт, що їхні прихильники частіше голосують достроково поштою,
і явка на нинішніх виборах зрештою у них може бути вищою, ніж у республіканців.
Проте високі шанси республіканців на перемогу турбують Київ і всіх у США, хто підтримує Україну в її боротьбі проти російської агресії.
Таких, згідно з опитуваннями, у США - абсолютна більшість. Водночас багато кандидатів від республіканців
напередодні виборів висловлювалися за обмеження підтримки Києва і навіть за повне її скасування.
Деякі з них виступають за невтручання у проблеми Європи та світу і закликають сконцентруватися на внутрішніх питаннях.
Ще у травні, коли Конгрес ухвалив закон про масштабний пакет допомоги Україні на загальну суму 40 мільярдів доларів,
- "за" проголосували всі демократи та більшість республіканців у Палаті представників, але 57 республіканців тоді висловилися "проти".
Поки що більшість республіканців, які керують фракціями партії у Конгресі, і особливо Мітч Макконнелл у Сенаті, активно виступають за допомогу Україні.
Як би там не було, політологи впевнені: більшість в обох партіях переконана у необхідності як військової, так і фінансової підтримки України.
На думку аналітиків, зовнішньополітичний курс США навряд чи зміниться після проміжних виборів.
Не думаю, що Республіканська партія отримає більшість у 60 голосів у Сенаті, а тому виникне багато патових ситуацій.
Крім того, у нас все ще є президент Байден, який, імовірно, накладе вето на будь-які законопроєкти, які висуне Республіканська партія
і які можуть сильно змінити політичний курс. Отже, як мені здається, ми швидше рухаємося до ще більшого застою в Конгресі.
На виборчі дільниці американці вирушать у вівторок 8 листопада, а Конгрес США у новому складі має розпочати роботу вже 1 січня.